中大膽週報
歡迎收看
公開版285集
台股好像真的
有遇到美股總經環境的一些壓力
但是在講壓力之前
我們今天很特別
有一個開場
DERREN
大家仔細看一下
中大膽出書囉
而且是他職業生涯
到目前為止
人生第一本書
第一本書
叫做一直盈超酷的
里面就有传授所谓的424心法
也是我们节目独家提到的
是没错
如果投资朋友有兴趣的话
我觉得这段时间可以去看这部分
因为最近的盘也很闷
反正利用这个时间可以好好的充电
我相信过半年之后
你会觉得这部分的价值会胜过于你的价格
几乎可以这么肯定讲
但不能讲百分百
有任何肯定距離的部分
那今天我要跟各位談的部分的走勢來講的話
我們先看大盤
這個大盤量能不足
在上個禮拜當中
週量還是持續創下這一波的晉級的一個新低量
那我想還是難免遇到一個尷尬的重點期就是
畢竟各國央行都要開始講出一些未來的貨幣政策的看法
所以在這個很不確定情況之下
市場上就很明顯就呈現一個觀望
加上目前的KD刚好处于超买区的部分
然后刚好向下弯
换句话说下个礼拜三台子级做结算
加上又有事务日又做结算
换句话说在这边来讲
最最重要只能看外资
上礼拜外资一下子买一下子卖
我们之前一直强调
如果你是动作派的
你就跟着外资操作
当然你就很有机会赚到一些钱
那如果你不是那种比较属于这种每天看盘的人
那我通常是比较属于头心派的
反正就你放买着机油股
那时间到了之后终究会开花结果
那我们看一下最近整个客厅的买盘有进来户盘
其实你不常买股票的人也看都知道
大家不外乎就是这段时间涨了什么
这个台积电
然后还有金融股
然后动不动军工股会动一动
那讲完之后大家就知道
这个应该就有课定的护盘
所以指数创高
但是呢在创高过程当中
我们可以发现到强势股
它没有延续性
没有
我相信这段时间
投资朋友如果你
按照过去的模式
今天强势股
然后明天再续报
跟你肯定讲
差不多很多公司
今天强势股完之后
明天又跌回去
来来回回
所以你会发现
你当天买强势股
接着第二天奇怪
怎麼要被扒
因為這個就是盤整盤的客色
好
我想下禮拜就觀察日圓的
這個大幅升值的
後續的效應是如何
我看那個BPI
日圓的部分
我剛來的時候還在跟你講
BPI
日本的PPI的部分
我將近有7%左右
比美國的這個PPI還高
那所以呢
基本上應該算是就應該
日壓應該會升息
那再来说是这波的上升趋势线
来到4万3千点以上
你说这个盘虽然是盘整盘
但是呢
它无形当中也把底部逐渐做一个垫高
所以我可以认为说在这个位置的话
我们就静观其变
不过在这个礼拜当中
我会把支撑把它往上提
整个市场上有没有人在护盘
我说真的
我们看都知道
一定有人在护盘
所以呢
要再跌到所谓的一个
我们讲的积极的所谓的一个
超买区的话我觉得有点难度了因为那支手应该不太会让它到那个位置去那我个人认为说这波当中事前我是认为4万4在做一个买进的动作
那我觉得如果拉回到4万5这附近的话
你就持股约先40%提升到50%
那投资朋友说那这样子会不会买贵
其实也不会啊
因为之前叫你卖掉4万5 4万6
差不多是这样这个位置
是不是觉得整理快要到尾巴了
我覺得已經慢慢
因為我之前提到過
越到10月初的時候
第10季的時候
這個部分的行情的走勢
我就要開始要做比較更積極的布局
但剛好現在這階段
央行有要
有別表態的想法
或許這個時候
你有可能可以買到這些的點數位置去
所以你看我還是會
很忠於我對大盤的指數的看法
未來會來5萬點
只是說是什麼時候買
只是說你的成本是用
多少的成本去买进
所以你现在不管是买在4万6
4万5 坦白讲以后都会到5万点
但是呢
就是多500点或多1000点或多2000点的问题
那我看最近的投信也没有在积极的卖了
所以呢我觉得他
如果我跟他的习性有某种程度很相似的话
我认为说他这波应该到4万5左右
应该就会比较积极的
是把他先前调节部分再买回来
那這次呢
如果拉回到千錢投信的佈局去44,000的話
你可以把它提升到6成到8成
如果拉回到43,000就剛我們看的上升趨勢線
你可以提高到8成到9成
至於42,000到40,000我覺得應該在選舉前應該很難
因為是剩下大概越來越接近只剩下兩個月的時間
不過這波來講因為反彈將近有上漲快七週
難免這一兩個禮拜應該會有一些壓回的機會
所以好好把握這一波壓回的時候當中
趕快佈局一些好公司的股票
今天我要講的一個部分就是
投資派應該會認為說
現在指數處在高檔位置
深怕你選錯股而虧損
坦白講選錯股而虧損難免的
大多數大家都看成功的案例
我今天就把我之前
我们在今年度所讲的一些股票
曾经在我讲完之后
尽量不到一个礼拜
或者是甚至在半个月当中
就可以中错两三成以上
两三成是很恐怖的
那表示它的跌幅是很快的
那这个部分来讲的话
我们先来讲来跟各位做说明
时间从1月到现在目前9月左右
大概总共有三档
有出现这样的案例
表示平均三个月才出一档
那我大概讲一下这三档
如果你是之前是我们的订阅户
我想你就应该可以回顾
我之前跟各位所讲的操作
第一个是3月22号第235集的时候
讲这家公司叫林航
如果大家包括你是公开版的人
应该有记忆犹新那时候
3月中的时候
当时有记忆体
集体的重挫
那当时我们讲这家铃航
当时算是最后一个啦
才开始往下跌
其实之前大家往下跌的时候
它还曾经有出现大涨的部分
不过奈何整个族群都往下跌
加上美意战争
那时候也开战
所以终究呢
大概那时候我们讲的价位
差不多150、160左右
不到一个月的时间
从150、160左右跌到只剩下100块
那你看
很恐怖吗
三四层就去了
但是呢
有我们的一个分批的操作法那这个分批的操作法的部分我想如果是订阅户你有之前按照我的方式去操作那其实上你可以发现到最后面呢
不仅是跌升反弹解套
甚至呢
各位发现到
后面还曾经来到还原全值的249块钱
比之前买的价位
还将近多出快有一倍
所以呢
这个叫做从亏又转盈
甚至又赚更多
那这个普货会讲的一直赢
这个模式
但是需要时间中间要一个半月
到两个月它就从谷底又慢慢的翻上来了
这个是在上半年
我刚才讲平均三个月发生一次
但这个才上半年才出现过一次
第二季的时候比较没有发生过
因为第二季大家知道大款是一路往上抽
但第三季到目前为止还没结束
已经发生过两档股票
第三期真的比较难
真的难操作
另外一档就是7月26号271集
讲华通
那华通那时候建议买的价格
大概就落在200块到205块
那为什么
因为这场股票我可以讲
是因为我们已经
请大家获利出场
所以我可以讲
大概是落在200到205块
因为它有一个限增价的保护
当然有限增价的保护也没有用
也没有用
因为他也从205块200块左右
一口气跌到154块钱
短短一个礼拜跌了快50块钱左右
那你看很快
但是呢
我们有我们的一个操作方式
那后来呢
各位发现后来的低轨卫星往上走
那你也发现到后来也曾经
大涨到250块到260块
那不管投资朋友后来是在哪个位置卖
我相信都是赚到钱
也是从亏转赢
而且是不到一个月到两个月的时间
马上就出现回来
其实我们刚刚看的银行
也是大概在两个月当中
就马上做解到获利
这是第二档部分
第三档呢
这个就不露名了
因为这个还没有完全出
在7月5号第265期
哇这个更惨
这个建议的时候
当时候盘是在47000
48000左右
奈何大盘从47000-48000一口气跌到4万点
那这张股票也从大概接近300块钱左右
一口气跌到142块
基本上就是腰斩
那腰斩呢
坦白讲一般人买到股票腰斩的时候
你一开始信心会很丧失
但是呢因为对基本面大概有点了解
所以这张股票
我们还是坚持我们的一个操作方式
跟我们订阅的会员
叫他要怎么样操作
所以你发现
到最近他的股价已经来到230多块
甚至前一阵子也来到240块钱
换句话说也是一样
不到两个月时间能够从亏转盈
而这是亏转盈还甚至是从腰斩
然后亏钱的情况之下
马上就出现一个所谓的赚钱动作
我想刚刚这三档股票
我去先做一個案例
是因為我今年操作
這些公司的股票的時候
讓我們的會員曾經有大幅的虧損
後來也幫他們做一個解套
甚至能夠賺錢
這些公司三檔大跌25%以上
有個共同的現象
他們都是主要熱門的族群股
如果你有操作
我相信應該對這些股票
應該有個概念
第二個
偶爾遇上台股大跌
不到一個禮拜時間大跌25%以上
我想这个包括先前的CPU也是有这样子
但后来这些CPU陆续都在下半年的时候
因为台积电出现一个大涨下来问题是你要经得住那段时间大跌的过程那这个部分就要考验基本面的功力的部分那重点是第三个是
不是遇上倒霉事
你就无法解决
我特别强调
不是盲目的摊贫
其实我刚刚所讲的
这些的东西
不是说叫投资朋友
一直买买买买买
因为那有那么多钱
那有我们的方式
那这就是我在书北上
有特别提到租坏
因为我在测试当中
全部都是用
我之前在这段时间
跟投资朋友分享的一些做法
全部都是把它套用在安律上
这个部分来讲
确实有看到一个逆转胜的部分
所以我想这个部分
也顺便打个广告一下
因为人生也只有第一本的著作
说第一本书
因为钟大胆真的是一个很谨慎
而且他需要时间累积的人
累积到这边
他真的觉得这些心法
是可以用书
因为大家知道书又不能兔兔盖盖
书又不能登了以后把它删掉
他就是要拿来传家的
所以里面的一些知识
know how 他要教给大家的
一定是可以很倦勇
让大家反复练习
是没有问题的法则
是 他在9月9号
就这礼拜刚发行
那大概通路的部分
大概应该陆续都已经铺上去
书店 博客来等等
那这部分呢
我把这本书
我讲到大概有
他有三大的课设
来跟大家讲一下
还是一样
用很简单的
第一个课设就是投资金句
如果你是订阅户
或者是你之前是公开版的订户来讲
应该知道我长期都会用投资金句
来做一个说明
就是要加深各位的印象
但是呢这个不用太复杂
你很好记
第二个部分呢
明确好牌
里面有好公司
讲难听点就叫名牌
就明确好牌
你看我都用词多么很清楚
第三个呢
教你三观发财
这就一般很难会这样讲到
因为毕竟我可以从乡里做到总经理
也是这家公司第一位有做这样子
甚至薪水呢
举个例子
在30岁的时候到40岁的时候
能够成长一倍
30岁到50岁的时候可以成长两倍
但这个部分是有一些方法
有一些技巧的部分
我在书上有跟各位来做一个说明
所以不管你是要学投资的金句
或者是你要看明确好牌
坦白讲那边的明确好牌
我相信大盘中错的时候
它都很受用
再来就是升官发财
那你除了在股票投资要赚钱外
你在本业的部分
我也希望你能够为你自己
多争取一些收入的部分
所以我想透过这个三个的部分
来跟各位做说明
至于呢
最重要的刚刚我讲的
那三档股票
不是所有股票
所有的方式都可以
用這樣的方式來解套
我會在我們的隱藏版當中
來跟各位講Keypoint部分
好 《中大膽》週報還是以個股為主啦
我看到有些人是說
自己很喜歡投資指數或是ETF
那當然是一個選擇
但是股票市場1700百檔
還是非常多人希望能夠投資股票來獲利
因為股票的魅力
個股就是在漲的時候
把那個距離拉開的時候
很過癮喔
對啊
所以喜歡個股的人還是非常多
市場的流通性
也要靠這些個股來支撐
所以如果希望訂閱我們的VIP
了解每一週中大膽在選股上的邏輯
還有會定期幫我們追蹤講過的股票的話
就幫我們訂閱起來
我會把訂閱的連結放在留言的第一則
當然今天比較特別的是
假如你需要說細細的品味中大膽這一生
對於投資理念的想法
那這一本一直贏股市的必勝法
也非常值得大家入手
可以回家慢慢的研讀
那我們就訂閱起來吧